now I'm going to show you something that  is going to totally blow your rocks off  [Music]  wouldn't be the Christmas shopping see  if the stores were any less cooler than  they have harder than they are about  jewelry except I'm I think I'm gonna buy  it  do you accept cash  this dress is very vintage in Latvia we  can percent off that's a play-doh Fun  Factory right there how much are these  1795  what do you come with them yes I'm  trying to find a German dog this is in  the badness  this is so much more than a bad  retail burning  [Applause]  before you go on the fall I just want to  give you a few tips on how to be there  good Seneca you sit on a throne of lies  [Applause]  [Music]  yes do you have a mistake  answered murders  here's your Christmas spirit  [Music]